I'm here in Bahrain with vice admiral
Brad Cooper the commander of U.S naval
forces in the Middle East and we are
here to talk about cutting-edge drone
technology and the future of the Navy so
thank you so much for your time here
today great to be here I'd like to start
with this concept of the Navy's future
Fleet what does that look like and what
percentage of the fleet is manned and
what percentage is unmanned the chief of
Naval operations Emma White gilday has
his laid out division that the future
Fleet is a combination of manned and
unmanned there are a large number of
efforts going on throughout the Navy to
achieve this Vision we're one of them
our Leading Edge effort is focused on
taking unmanned surface vessels and
integrating those with artificial
intelligence to put more eyes out on the
water which expands our knowledge of
what's Happening that contributes to
Greater deterrence greater vigilance and
greater Regional security which is good
for everybody and of course it's not
just about these individual vessels it
is about what the Navy calls digital
ocean can you explain that yeah in
simple terms the digital ocean is a
synthesis of all the sensors that we can
pull together from seabed to space
sensors that are on the water under the
water in the sky bringing them all
together to enhance our understanding of
what's happening on above and underneath
the sea so what sort of capabilities
does a digital ocean give the US Navy
today we integrate manned systems with
these new unmanned systems and the
technology and what does that give us it
allows us to see further than we've been
able to see in the past you couple that
with artificial intelligence and you now
give yourself the opportunity in a very
large theater to detect things that a
human couldn't detect and then bring
that information back into a command
center so that a human can make a
decision big picture though it allows us
to increase our deterrence and our
understanding what's happening around
the theater so that we can use our man
vessels more effectively and you are are
rapidly testing and integrating them but
you've also been using some of these
unmanned vessels in the past few months
can you tell us what you have learned
from those vessels yeah we're doing both
of those so we are definitely
experimenting taking a Cutting Edge
technology bringing it from around the
world and bringing it here as we're
doing today and then we're integrating
with artificial intelligence and then
we're also operating it in on the
operational side we do manned and
unmanned teaming where we take these new
platforms and we team with a man vessel
to get the most out of what the sensors
can provide we're very happy with where
we are in the direction we're headed
there one event that made a lot of news
was Iran tried to seize two of these
drones that you've been using as you put
more unmanned vessels in the water does
the potential for conflict increase yeah
I think it's first important to note
that from our interaction with Iran that
their actions were flagrant they were
unwarranted they certainly weren't the
actions that we'd expect with a
professional Naval force and most
importantly their actions were a
violation of international law beyond
that we have not changed our operating
patterns the United States Navy and our
partners fly and sail with international
law allows and that's what we'll
continue to do in the future how is the
Navy preparing for and thinking about
the proliferation of these unmanned
vessels not just Americas but
competitors and allies around the world
well right now we're on the Leading Edge
of it and our goal is to stay on the
Leading Edge how close behind are other
countries China Russia Iran yeah I would
I wouldn't try to gauge you know how
close they are we're definitely leading
in this space and we're particularly
leading with the ability to integrate
not just the platforms but with
artificial intelligence and I'll tell
you the secret sauce that allows us to
do that is the people that we that we
have the people or that are allowing us
both success at the beginning
reassessment very quick adjustment and
be able to bring things to a closure in
a very effective way so that's really
how we're going to maintain the
advantage it's my understanding too that
task force 59 has inspired other task
forces throughout the military to do
similar work with sensors and
surveillance reconnaissance how
ultimately will these task forces and
these efforts integrate together yeah
I'll just use the example here in U.S
Central Command where we have all the
service components so task force 59 is
the Navy component the Air Force's ninth
Air Force now has a task force 99 the
U.S Army's third Army has task force 39.
so these three components will work
together under a common vision from the
centcom commander to advance our
Innovation and that helps the Navy and
the US military broadly see ocean floor
to space absolutely seabed to space
integrating sensors in the most dynamic
vibrant way that we can so none of the
platforms that are being used here or
experimented with here are armed is that
correct we're focused on domain
awareness right now that's correct but
as the war in Ukraine has showed us
drones armed drones in the sky and in
the water will inevitably play a very
big role in the future of warfare how is
the Navy how is the military preparing
for armed vessels armed systems in the
water yeah I think we all recognize that
the arm systems in the air have been
around for 20 to 30 years at this point
underneath the sea you have sensors that
have operated unmanned undersea vehicles
for about 10 years and so we're on the
Leading Edge of this work on the surface
right now we're focused on the domain
awareness and understanding of what's
happening and I'm certain in the future
we'll look to advance the capability can
you tell me more about the importance of
Israel's participation in your efforts
yeah a couple things about Israel number
one they're an extraordinary capable
Navy and Military so having them in a
partner adds value you to Maritime
security particularly in the Red Sea and
that's good for everybody more
specifically both the Abraham Accords
and their transition in alignment from
U.S European command to your Central
Command has allowed us to work more
closely than we've ever been able to
work before so in the last year just
from a bilateral basis we've done more
than 30 exercises with Israel enhancing
our overall proficiency interoperability
and then more broadly because they are
quite proficient at Sea and in
multi-domains and in unmanned they bring
extra value to the sensors that are
participating in this exercise and again
I think at the end of the day you'll
find their participation helps ensure
increase in deterrence and greater
Regional stability that's good for the
free flow of Commerce and that's good
for everybody in the region
you're building out a fleet of 100
unmanned platforms by the end of next
summer that will be an international
Fleet is that correct yeah the goal is
as you mentioned 100 unmanned surface
vessels patrolling the waters around the
Middle East by the end of next summer
the United States would have about 20 of
those but our partner nations would
resource the remaining 80 and we're on
path to do that what we do offer now is
the latest and greatest that's out there
both in unmanned systems and artificial
intelligence Admiral Cooper thank you so
much thanks great to chat with you
appreciate it it's great to be here